hey youtubers is Charlie a couple days
after I talk about flash episode 1 they
officially dropped the release dates for
everything and is a big problem with
arrows I'll explain what's going on
summer flash ring giveaway continues all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
but the really good news is we know all
the dates for everything that's coming
back is basically starting the second
week in October which is pretty close to
when it premieres every year but the
really big problem this year is arrow
because arrow season 6 is going to be on
Thursday nights on the CW at 9 p.m.
that's really good because they can be
more violent they can be more graphic
maybe a little more skin agents of
shield did the same thing when it went
from 8 p.m. to 9 p.m. and then to 10
p.m. the later it moved in the night the
more hardcore it got until we got to
Ghost Rider and it got super hardcore
which I think that everybody liked so I
think it's a good move for arrow
hopefully they'll be able to make use of
Deathstroke pending Manu Bennett trying
to get that destro spinoff series off
the air but it looks like the Canadian
station CTV 2 the airs arrow is going to
keep it on Wednesday nights so we have
this crazy situation where you might be
able to watch arrow a night early before
it airs in the United States most of my
viewers are in the United States but a
lot of you guys live internationally so
you can just let me know how you usually
watch these shows normally it's the
other way around so it creates a problem
for doing videos about it because I
could always do the videos when it's
airing on Wednesday night but if
everybody's not going to be able to
watch the episode till Thursday there's
not much of a reason to do that there's
already a bunch of people in Great
Britain that we're asking me about
Gotham because I just did a couple
finale videos for that and they haven't
even gotten season 3 yet for some reason
they're broadcaster hasn't aired it so
it's a bit of a nightmare but everything
else is on the same night legends of
tomorrow is still going to be right
after the flash they're both coming back
on the 10th Supergirl is still on Monday
nights the new Black Lightning show
isn't premiering till midseason so it'll
be spring 2018 and it sounds like the
same thing is going to happen for the
new Titans TV show but that's going to
air on the DC streaming service it won't
be on the CW like the other DC TV shows
so don't worry too much about that yet
but we talked a little bit about episode
1 of the flash they just have to do
their version of rebirth pickup with
Wally
being the main version of the flash and
then explain how Barry is going to come
back there'll be a couple more flash
bonus videos this weekend but I've been
getting a lot of questions about which
characters I want to see back something
really cool happened that might make it
possible for hunter zolomon to come back
to the TV show because even though it
seems like they killed him they killed
the black flash at the end of season 3
we have a big wide multiverse so hunter
can still come back
zoom can even come back to because
infinite universes there are probably a
couple other versions of hunter that
became soo so Teddy Sears show got
cancelled he was on the 24 Legacy TV
show that went up in smoke meaning that
if he doesn't have another job book then
he's totally available to come back the
actress that plays patty spivot also
said that she was going to try and come
back during season 3 it didn't end up
working out but she said it was all
about scheduling she's on another TV
show so she's trying to come back to in
the sort of status pending on what's
going to happen with Prison Break so it
looks like captain cold and heat wave
will also be available to come back to
because I think the heat wave is
continuing with legends of tomorrow but
captain colds contract status is still
up in the air they're probably
negotiating with the actors right now
they just started writing the season
this past week the arrow writers have
been posting a whole bunch of stuff like
look at this board we're starting today
there's nothing on it it'll be totally
full in a couple weeks but as for arrow
really the only person that's been
confirmed dead Early's supposedly dead
is John Barrowman Malcolm Merlyn
character in Captain Boomerang because
if one of them was going to die in that
explosion they both thought it probably
died because he was standing right next
to him but because Manu Bennett is
shooting that shannara chronicles' TV
show in New Zealand it's pretty fair to
say that he'll pop up in that first
episode then he'll go off and try to
find Jericho in repairers family and
most of that adventure will just take
place off screen so that whenever he
pops back up he'll tell us hey you know
I found him this is what you guys missed
in the six months that I was away so I
don't think that Manu Bennett is ever
going to be a regular on arrow again but
it would be amazing if he was even if
he's not going to get that Deathstroke
series there been a lot of you asking me
to do a video for that I think it's very
unlikely that it's going to happen but I
will do a comic book story video for
things that I think they could adapt I
already talked a little bit about Titans
crossover using the last
his contract story line so I had a link
for that video at the end of this but as
for legends of tomorrow
now that arrow is moving to Thursdays it
sort of opens up a window so I'll
probably be posting those videos on
Wednesdays and they confirmed Isis which
means that the rock of eternity Black
Adam Shazam exists in the air over
somewhere but it's kind of like Batman
existing Batman does exist in the air
overs but they had to be really careful
about the way they reference them I'll
have to do a montage video sometime this
summer with all the moments that they
referenced Batman as evidence that he
exists but beyond Isis they just said
that it's going to get a lot crazier
time is collapsed on itself but you have
stuff from 2030 and you have stuff from
the time of the dinosaurs existing in
the same space because of the way they
broke time so I know I'm due for a
legends of tomorrow video so I'll do
something for that soon because I'm just
really happy with what it opens the door
to because they can do Isis stuff they
don't have to do Black Adam to do Isis
but because the rock is going to be
playing him in a movie really soon and
he's getting a solo Black Adam movie
it's not going to be some crappy cameo
they're probably going to want to keep
him off the screen on the TV shows just
so that he gets to debut in the film
universe first usually after that
happens then they're open to them
showing up on the TV shows Nightwing on
Titans is an exception to that I think
just because Geoff Johns is such a
powerful person and it sounds like
Warner Brothers is a little more willing
to let him do what he wants to with that
just because of what he's done so far in
the DC EU Wonder Woman is such a
slam-dunk but when your name is Geoff
Johns it's just a lot easier to jam your
foot in the door and say I want to use
these characters so I'm gonna do it if
all right
it was about to say the same to you
three I fear we leave the more dangerous
task here on earth we'll manage time to
go leave all your requests for DC TV
videos in the comments below there's all
kinds of arrow Deathstroke legends of
tomorrow there's some more blast this
weekend I'm going to try and work in
some Marvel stuff too there was a new
Infinity Ward that I meant to do before
a bunch of this other stuff drop so I'll
try to post that as soon as possible too
so whole bunch of stuff coming if you
couldn't tell I changed the audio just a
little bit on this video so let me know
if you think it sounds better than the
other DC TV videos that I've been
posting recently but congratulations to
magic Mart
three you the latest giveaway winner
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here for brand
new flash and you can click here for
brand new Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight